الحقائب الوزاريه الوازنه لحكومه نتنياهو
الناشئه وقعت في قبضه متطرفين يحملون
ايديولوجيات عنصريه يقول الاسرائيليون ان
استسلام ناتن يهوبات واضحا خاصه على
الصعيد الامني بعد منحه سلطات واسعه
لشريكيه بتليلس مودريتش وتمر بني كبير
القسام داخل المجتمع الاسرائيلي هذه
الكتله حقيقه وان كانت تتمسح بالصهيونيه
هي ليست كذلك لا تؤمن بالقيم التي اسستت
عليها الحركه الصهيونيه
المساواه بين الرجل والمراه بين المواطنين
بين مكونات الشعب داخل اسرائيل
سيتولى منصبه وزير الامن القومي وسامح
السيطره المباشره على حارس الحدود بحيث
يكون قادرا على التاثير على التعليمات
للقوات
بتوفير الحصانه للجنود والشرطه
الاسرائيليه لاطلاق النار والذي اعتبره
الفلسطينيون اعطاء الجنود تصريحا غير
محدودا للقتل
لا شك في انه اسرائيل اليوم امام مواقع
غريب وغير مضبوط حيث انه مجموعه من
المتطرفين الذين لم يخدموا بالجيش انا جيش
حقيقه لم يتقبلهم بسبب ماضيهم المشاهب في
صباهم يريدون التحكم في المؤسسه العسكريه
واملائه جدتهم المتطرفه والعنصريه على على
الجيش وقوى الامن
الدينيه سيتولى منصب وزيرا في وزاره الامن
وسيطر على الاداره المدنيه وسيكون تعزيز
وتوسيع الاستيطان وتهجير مزيدا من العرب
من اولوياته
على ما يبدو حكومه نتنياهو الناشئه ستؤدي
الى فوض داخليه وتاكلي دعم الناخبين
العلمانيين لحزب اليكود اضافه لتفجير
الوضع الميداني في الضفه الغربيه المحتله
وافسادهم طبقه من علاقات بين اسرائيل
والسلطه الفلسطينيه لان كل غاصي من القدس
العربيه